[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبارهم
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
افغانستان
النيابه العامه السعوديه
مصادر العربيه تكشف عن بدء صحه السعوديه
تفعيل المستشفيات العامه لعيادات الادمان
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
اكثر من 700 الف ناخد عمانيه يبداون
التصويت الكترونيا لاختياري اعضاء المجلس
البلديه
السياحه السعوديه تعلن عن عشر لوائح جديده
لتحقيق مستهدفات استراتيجيه السياحه
الوطنيه
حياكم الله اعلنت ثلاث منظمات غذائيه
اجنبيه انها ستعلق عملها في افغانستان بعد
قرار طالبان بحظر عمل النسائي بالمنظمات
غير الحكوميه وجاء في بين المشترك
للمنظمات الثلاث وهي انقذ الاطفال والمجلس
النرويجي للاجئين انهم سيعلقون برامجهم في
افغانستان مطالبين بمواصله قيام الرجال
والنساء بشكل متساوي بتقديم المساعدات
التي تنقذ الارواح
هذا هو حضر نائب ومنسق الشؤون الانسانيه
للامم المتحده في افغانستان رامز الاكبره
الذي سيلتقي سلطات طالبان اليوم حذر من ان
قرار طالبان حضر عمل النسائي في المنظمات
غير الحكوميه سيؤثر بشكل خطير على عمليات
الشؤون الانسانيه والاغاتيه لافغانستان
الى جانب ان برامج الامم المتحده ستتاثر
وقالت وكاله المعونه الدوليه افغان ان
تعليق العمليات حدث على الفور وان اكثر من
نصف السكان يعتمدوا على المساعدات
الانسانيه
من جانبه حضر وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انتونيو بلينك من ان قرار طالبان بمنع
النساء من العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
سيعطل تسليما المساعدات وقد يكون مدمره
لافغانستان وكتب على موقع تويتر انه يشعر
بقلق عميق من ان قرار طالبان سيعطل
المساعده الحيويه
والمنقذه لحياه الملايين
ينضم الينا من كابل احد العاملين
بالمنظمات الدوليه بافغانستان حمزه حكيمي
سيد حمزه مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض انت تعمل في احد المنظمات الاغاثيه
الدوليه في كابول هل اوقفتم
عملياتكم بعد قرار طالبان بحضر عمل النساء
تحياتي لكم الاستاذ المشاهدين الكرام
عليكم استشار في احدى المنظمات الاغاثيه
الدوليه في كابول
تاثرنا جدا سلبيا عن هذا القرار
وبما ان منظمتنا نحن لم تتوقف الى الان
لكن ستتاثر بشكل كبير كل فعاليات المؤسسه
مؤلفات هذه المؤسسه الاغاثيه في افغانستان
كما ان هناك يعني مؤسسات منظمات اضافيه
كبرى اخرى قد تعطلت وقد توقفت عن العمل
بشكل كامل لان هذا القرار قرار محب جدا
وقرار يعني ستثير مشاكل عديده في ايصال
الخدمات لشعب الافغاني
عملياتكم حمزه
الفعل المستهدفه او المستفيده من خدمات
المواساه الاغاثيه شريحه كبيره منها
النساء والفتيات في قطاع الصحه قطاع
التنميه البشريه قطاع الاغاثه قطاع المواد
التنميه التموينيه وغيرها من القطاعات
الاخرى مثلا النساء ذوي الاعاقه في
افغانستان الخزانات التي تقدم لكل هذه
الفئات من النساء والفتيات تقدمها
العاملات في هذه المؤسسات من النساء فاذا
منعنا هذه هؤلاء النساء من العمل في
المؤسسات من سيقدم هذه الخدمات في
افغانستان وفي القرى وفي المناطق النائيه
لكل هذه الفتيات والنساء همم فالعاملات في
هذه المؤسسات من جانب همم من جانب من
هؤلاء الى عاملات همم يعني تعتبر همم يعني
اعمالهن في المؤسسات والمنظمات الاغاثيه
المصدر الوحيد لمعظم هذه العاملات
لعوائلهم ومن جانب الاخر الخدمات التي
تقدم من قبل هذه المؤسسات
لشريحه النساء في افغانستان ااا ستتوقف
لان الرجال لا يمكنهم ان يقدموا العديد من
هذه الخدمات للنساء في همم بيئه تقليديه
مثل اب مثل افغانستان
فالنساء في افغانستان ستتاثرن من عدم
العمل
متعلقه بالنساء ربما العاجزات او النساء
همم يعني همم التي يعني يطلبن خدمات ربما
لا تقدمها سوى النساء لهن يعني فهل بحثتم
هذه النقطه مع طالبان او اثارتهم هذه
النقطه بعد ابلاغكم بهذا ال- ال- الخبر
خبر تعليق عمل للنساء في منظمتكم
يبدو الى الان ان يبدو المسؤولين الان غير
مبالين بهذه الامور المسؤولين في الحكومه
الطالبان هم فقد اصدروا القرار وس يعني
غير مبرر الى الان ب- ااا يعني باثارها
هذا القرار على المجتمع الافغاني وعلى
الشريحه المستفيده من شعب الافغاني
المعظمهم للفقراء الذين يستفيدون من هذه
الخدم لان الحكومه بنفسها غير قادره على
تقديم على هذه الخدمات فمثلا في القطاع
الصحي همم يعني نسبه كبيره من الخدمات
القطاع الصحي تقدمها المنظمات الاغاثيه
الدوليه في افغانستان في معظم الولايات
همم ومعظم المناطق والكره همم فاذا منعنا
همم العاملات في هذه المؤسسات من تقديم
الخدمات والمجتمع الافغاني لا تسمح لتقديم
هذه الخدمات من قبل الرجال الصحيه للنساء
فهذا بالطبع سيزيد من الضغط همم داخل
المجتمع على افغاني وهذا الضغط سيشعره
المسؤولين المسؤولون همم بدرجه الاولى في
الحكومه في حكومه الطالبات لذلك نرى ان
يعني هناك قلق بالغ وقلق شديد في وسط
المسؤولين في المنظمات الاغاثيه الدوليه
وقلق بين العاملين والعاملات في هذه
القطاع ممتاز تتحدث عن قلق تتحدث ايضا عن
ان النساء سيتاثرن ايضا بايقاف عمل هذه
المنظمات ونسال هنا عن البديل لهذه
المنظمات سيد حمزه ما هو البديل اذا غادرت
هذه المنظمات الدوليه الاغاثيه الانسانيه
في افغانستان وهي التي تعاني من اوضاع
اقتصاديات توصف بالصعبه وانسانيه توصف
بالاصعب حتى كذلك
همم بطريقه الحاله المسؤوليه على عاتق
الحكومه على عاتق الجماعه التي تدير
الحكومه الان وتعتبر نفسها بانها الحكومه
تشكل الحكومه في افغانستان لكن بوجود
المؤسسات الاجنبيه والاضافيه الاجنبيه في
افغانستان الحكومه غير قادره على تقديم
هذه الخدمات فبعد مغادره هذه المؤسسات من
افغانستان بكل تاكيد ستتفاقم الازمه بشكل
كبير وسيزيد الضغط على اعتق الحكومه التي
هي اصلا عاجزه عن تقديم الخدمات للشعب
الخدمات في المختلفه في القطاعات التي
تغطيها هذه المنظمات الاغراثيه همم البديل
بدل على الحكومه ان تقدم بديلا وهي اصلا
عاجزه عن تقديم البديل لكن همم على اي حال
الضحيه ستكون شعبا الافغاني الذي يعيش
اكثر من
79% من هذا شعب تحت خط الفقر وهي شعب وهو
شعب محتاج جدا لهذه همم
المساعدات الانسانيه والاضافيه لكن هذا
الشعب
ااا يعني يدفع القيمه وسيكون الضحيه طيب
همم هل لديكم معلومات او تفاصيل عن
المنظمات الاجنبيه التي اعلنت انها ستعلق
عمالها في افغانستان قبل قليل يتحدث عن
ثلاث منظمات حتى هذه اللحظه انت مستشار في
احد هذه المنظمات الاغاثه الدوليه يا سيد
حمزه هل لديك معلومات
يعني بعض الاتحادات لهذه المناسبات او كما
يقال امبريلا اورجانيزيشن يعني همم منظمات
يعني اتحادات همم
تنضم تحتها العديد من هذه المنظمات اليوم
كان هناك يعني مجالس عديده بين هذه
المنظمات المختلفه واا سيصدر قرار موحد من
قبل همم المنظمات الاغاثيه الدوليه
والمنظمات الاغاثيه المحليه هناك يعني همم
مجموعه اخرى من المنظمات الاغاثيه الاهليه
الافغانيه داخل افغانستان همم في همم في
اتحاد لهذه المنظمات فسيكون هناك قرار
موحد همم من قبل هذه المنظمات ونحن في هذا
حاله من الترقب حتى يكون هناك موقف موحد
وحتى يعني همم وهذا الموقف همم يعني سيكون
له تاثير على همم هذا القرار وسيكون له
تاثير على مستقبل العمل الاغاثي لهذه
المنظمات
رزيل الشكر من كابو المستشار باحدى
المنظمات الغذائيه الدوليه بافغانستان
حمزه حكيمي ومتابعته لهذا الموضوع ايضا
ينضموا الينا هنا في الاستديو الصحه في
الافغاني احمد سيد سيد احمد مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياض كما سمعت قبل
قليل الحديث من احد مستشاري المنظمات بان
هذا العمل الاغاثه والانساني سيتاثر في
افغانستان خصوصا في فئه النساء من ستتاثر
قبل ذلك اريد ان اسال عن المنظمات التي
اعلنت بانها ستوقف عملياتها تماما في
افغانستان همم كم وصل عددها الى حد الى
الان وكيف تم ابلغها اصلا
نكمل بلاغ هذه المنظمات عبر خطاب رسمي من
وزير الاقتصاد اصدر اليهم ان لم ينفذ هذه
القرارات سيتم تحت رخيصهم تصاريح تواجدهم
في افغانستان هذا المنظمات بدايه مجلس
السويدي اليفغانستان المجلس النرويجي
لشؤون اللاجئين في افغانستان والمجلس
الدنماركي لشؤون اللاجئين في افغانستان
وكذلك منظمه تنقذ الاطفال هذه المنظمات
فوجئت يوم امس على نهايه
العمل الرسمي يوم امس على نهايه الدوام
الدوام الرسمي تم وصل لهم الخطابات بان
هذا القرار نافذ من اليوم من من يوم الغد
لان يحضر اي لن تحضر الفتاه الى العمل في
المنظمات سيتم من يخالف همم سيتم سحب
تراخيصهم لذلك هذه المنظمات بنفسها قدمت
يوما في بياناتها بانها سوف تنسحب من
افغانستان تعلق اعمال المكاتبها
بالنظر اليوم همم سيد احمد للوضع الانساني
في في افغانستان وضع الاقتصادي ايضا كذلك
المطر المتردي اكثر من 70% من سكان يعيشون
تحت خط الفقر اغلبهم يحتاج لمساعدات غازيه
وانسانيه من هذه المنظمات كيف ستتاثر
الحياه خصوصا النساء
تاثير كبير جدا نستناك لا يمكن ان يتم
اخفاء هذا التاثير ابدا مثلا
المجلس النرويجي لشؤون اللاجئين لديهم 470
فتاه موظفه لديهم يعني وهم يعملوا لنا
مجلس النرويجي يعملون منذ
2001 في افغانستان ولديهم ما يقارب همم
اكثر من اثنين مليون مستفيد سنويا من
الشونه الاعمال الوراثيه والانسانيه من
ناحيه اخرى على المجلس السويدي لديهم سته
الاف موظفه افغاني متواجدين في افغانستان
في كافه نحافه افغانستان
والمجلس السويدي يستفيد منه سنويا اثنين
مليون افغاني في الخدمات الصحيه وسبعه
و80,000 طالب يدرسون في المدارس التي همم
التابعه للم الصوره دي اا بالطبع هذه
بمجرد ان تعلق يعني نحن نجد ان اثار
ستترتب على التعليم الغذاء
وكذلك حتى الصحه وكذلك همم مجالات الايواء
والاغاثه لهم فهمم خصوصا النساء يعني
الاعداد الكبيره في هذه المنظمات النساء
يعمل يعني خصوصا لان القرى او همم المدن
البعيده والقرى البعيده تحتاج الى العم-
الى العمل النساء بخصوصا مع الاسر التي
هناك
يعني
[موسيقى]
هذا الامر يعني يسبب ضرر على النساء
الافغاني بشكل عام يعني هذه منظمات كبيره
احنا نشاهد هذه الصور هذا الفيديو
لنساء افغانيات تظاهرنا اليوم في ولايه
نمروز في افغانستان ضد طبعا منع التعليم
للفتيات هذه الصوره التي نتبعها اذا هناك
رفض نسائي في
انحاء الدوله في انحاء افغانستان حول هذه
القرارات يعني التي وصفت بانها التعسفيه
ضد النساء بدايه بمنعهم من تعليم الجامعي
وصولا الى حضر طالبا على الموظفات همم
في المنظمه طبعا غير الحكوميه كيف تعلق
اولا على هذه الصوره سيده احمد
مظاهرات يعني خرجت منذ ايام كذلك في عدد
من الولايات في افغانستان تمدد وتدين قرار
طالبان وتعترض على قرار طالبان المجتب بحق
المراه في افغانستان همم من التعليم ومن
ثم اليوم التالي منع من العمل في المنظمات
غير الحكوميه
هذه قرارات مجرفه من طالبان بحق النساء في
افغانستان محاولات اقساط تحت مبررات نحن
كفقان نجدها مبررات غير منطقيه مبررات وهي
لا صحه لها هي فقط محاوله
فرض فكر فكر طالبان على الشعب الافغاني
فرض الفكر هذا المتشدده من منع المراه من
العمل
والتاليات يعني وباختصار شديد هل يمكن ان
تقابل هذه الخطوات احتجاجات كبيره في
الشارع الافغانيه على غرار مثلا مع فارق
التشبيه ما حدث في ايران مثلا
ولم تتراجع عن قراتها خصوصا لديانات
الدوليه الكبيره للقرار القرارات طالبان
الاخيره فاعتقد ان هذه همم ستزداد هذه
الاحتجاجات خصوصا ان هناك عدد من الاساتذه
حتى الطلاب الشباب همم اساتذه استقاله
الجامعات استق منصبهم طلاب الجامعه تعرف
اصدروا بيانات مشتركه الطلاب والكليات في
مختلفه الجامعات الافغانيه اصدروا بيانات
مشتركه مشتركه بانهم لن يحضروا الى الصفوف
الدراسيه اذا لم تتراجع طالبان عن هذا
القرار يعني اشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك
معي على كل هذه تفصيلات ومعلومات كان معي
هنا في الاستديو الصحفي الافغاني احمد سيد
شكرا جزيلا
اصدرت نيابه العامه السعوديه
لجمع الادله والمعلومات والتحريب اللازمه
للتحقيق وتوجيه الاتهامات الدليل السعودي
شمله عمليات العده منها عمليات الكشف
للسباقي لجرائم غسل الاموال ورصد
التعاملات الماليه المشبوهه
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو المحامي فهد
القصير سيف فهد مرحبا بكمال في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض حياك الله خلينا نعرف
اولا ايش معنى حوكمه اجراءات مكافحه
التستر وعلى اي اسس قانونيه تم اجرائها
واصدارها همم اولا اسعد الله مساك بالخير
والمسرات اخو نايف انا سعيد اننا نتحدث عن
الحكم القانونيه والحدث الجديد الذي يسعى
الى ضبط اجراءات او كمل جريمه مكافحه
التستر التجاري لدى جهات الضبط اولا في
البدايه على الاسس القانونيه اللي تمت
اجراءات الحكم عليها ابتداءا من قبل نيابه
الاجرام الاقتصاديه في النيابه العامه
بالتعاون مع وزاره التجاره كجهاز بالضبط
استنادا على الماده ال 25 من نظام
الاجراءات الجزائيه الصادر بتاريخ
22/01/1435 وفق المرسوم الملكي مين تقسيم
اثنين الذي نصت على ان الجهه النيابه
العامه هي جهه اش على جهات الضبط في جميع
الجرائم سواء في مكافحه التستر التجاري او
غيرها
كذلك نص نظام التستر التجاري في الماده
الخامسه في الفقره الاولى والفقره الثانيه
على ان تختص البلاغات وتلقي اجراءات الضبط
لمكافحه التستر التجاري او لجريمه التستر
التجاري خاصه في وزاره التجاره وما يتعلق
في التحقيق واجراءات التحقيق غير متعلقه
في النيابه العامه من هذا الباب اتحدت
وزاره التجاره والنيابه العامه واتفقوا
على تعاون في اصدار دليل اجراءات لحكمه
مكافحه التستر التجاري بشكل كامل
الاجرائي لمكافحه التستر التجاري فقط
هذا فقط متعلق بالاقتصاد والتجاري متعلق
فقط في جريمه التستر التجاري دون سواها
ممتاز طيب ايش الفائده من حكمت الاجراءات
هذه اليوم نشوفها اشرح ممكن يتغير في في
في في الاجراءات والتعامل مع اي قضايا
يعني نتحدث عن الحكمه كجزء بسيط ومن ثم
اوكمه الاجراءات اولا اذا نظرنا الى
المحكمه في معناها العام فهي وعدد من
النظوم التي تحدد الجميع الاطراف احيا
الموضوع معين سواء شركات مساهمه او شركات
همم ذات مسؤوليه محدوده في تحدد العلاقه
بين جميع الاطراف اذا نظرنا الى حوكم
الدليل الاجراءات في مكافحه جريمه ستر
التجاري فهي حوكمه اجراءات تحدد علاقه
جميع الاطراف وحدد علاقه النيابه العامه
تحدد علاقه وزاره التجاره تحدد علاقه
المتهمين كذلك تحدد علاقه الاجراءات
المتعلقه في الضبط ومن ثم الرفع للجهه
القضائيه فحوكم الدليل الاجراءات معناته
انه نحدد العلاقه المتعلقه في هذه الجريمه
من جميع الاطراف جهات فقط جهات تحقيق
متهمين واقعه جنائيه ممتاز همم طيب
الدليل الاجرائي ايضا يعني نبغى نعرف اكثر
ايش يشتمل عليه
ما اهم النقاط اللي موجوده فيه اللي ممكن
البناء عليها او انه نعرف انه في حوكما
يعني محكمه في في موضوع الاجراءات التستر
ومكافحه
الحكم وفق البيان الصادر حوكمه دليل
اجراءات مكافحه جرائم ستره التجاري لدى
جهات الضغط من من ذات الاعلان اللي صدر
فهي ما هي الاجراءات التي ترتب ويتحكم على
جهات الضبط القيام بها واعداد ملف متكامل
للرفع للنيابه العامه ومن ثم النظر بجهاد
التحقيق في النيابه العامه والادعاء بذلك
امام الجهات القضائيه في المحاكم الجزائيه
المتخصصه دليل الاجراءات نص على ثلاث
محاور اساسيه اولا صياغه قانونيه متحده
لدى جميع الاشياء القانونيه والماليه لذلك
لتحقيق رغبه القناعه عند القضاء
لحين يتم الترافع ما بين المتهمين وما بين
النيابه العامه تكون الاجراءات موحده في
جميع جهات الضبط في جميع اماكن النيابه
العامه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ثانيا
كان الدليل الاجراءات الحوكمه نص على
اجراءات قانونيه ماليه متحده الكشف عن
مصادر غسل الاموال قضايا غسل الاموال قبل
ارتكابها الكشف عن مشروعيه المال من
المتصرف الحقيقي في الاموال بطرق محدده
ثالثا كانت هناك صياغه لمصطلحات قانونيه
والاساليب الظاهره وغير الظاهره لجريمه
مكافحه التستر التجاري بشكل موحد لدى جميع
فروع النيابه العامه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معي
هنا همم الرابعه المحامي فهد القصير شكرا
لك عفوا
الرابع مستمرات تتابعون فيها بعد قليل
مصادر العربيه تكشف عن بدء صحه السعوديه
تفعيل المستشفيات العامه لعيادات الادمان
حياكم الله من جديد كشفت مصادره العربيه
في السعوديه عن بدء اولى مراحل لتفعيل
العيادات الادمان في المستشفيات العامه
بعدما كانت عمليات العلاج حصرا في
المستشفيات النفسيه متخصصه وشملت المرحله
الاولى من المبادره الصحيه 50 مستشفى حول
السعوديه حيث جرى تدريب العاملين بها
وتعريفهم بعمليات علاج الادمان لتعزيز
جوده الخدمات المقدمه
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو استشاري الطب
النفسي وقائد طب الادمان بوزاره الصحه
الدكتور حسن الخبران دكتور حسن حياك الله
نشاط الرابع علاج الادمان اصبح وعيادات
علاج الادماء الادمان اصبحت تتواجد في
المستشفيات العامه اريد ان اعرف كيف ستكون
اليه تطبيقها والفرق بينها وبين عيادات
الامل السابق
عيادات
الادمان بالمستشفيات العامه هي همم يعتبر
مرض الادمان من الامراض النفسيه وتوجد من
صفات العامه عيادات طبيه نفسيه تقدم
الخدمات الطبيه النفسيه لكافه الامراض
منها همم طب الادمان ونظرا ل همم بالتواصل
مباشر مع بعض همم
المقدمين الخدمه افاده بوجود حاجتهم
للتعريف باليه التعامل مع الحالات اللي
همم
تكون لها حاجه لعلاج الادمان
فتم ترشيح عدد من المستشفيات
وقد عقد ورشه تدريبيه تدريبيه تعريفيه
بكيفيه التعامل مع مثل هذه الحالات كيفيه
تحويلها كيفيه التعامل معها ما هي الحالات
التي تعتبر ضمن نطاق الخدمه وما هي
الحالات التي تعتبر خارج نطاق الخدمه
الدكتور حسن المستشفيات اليوم لدينا هل هي
جاهزه فعلا لتستقبل هذه الحالات يعني احنا
نعرف انه في كثير مستشفيات مثلا يتم فيها
علاج بعض حالات الصحه النفسيه لكن الادمان
يعني مرحله معقده نوعا ما يعني في في
مساله الصحه النفسيه هل المستشفيات جاهزه
على الكوادر مدربه بشكل همم حتى يتم تعميم
هذه التجربه لا تقتصر فقط على 50 مستشفى
صحيح اتفق معك الانطباع الاولي والاساسي
للتعامل مع الادمان على انه همم مستوى
واحد الادمان مستويات فيه البسيط وفيه
المتوسط وفيه شديد همم توجد الكثير
الحالات التي تفقد وهي في المرحله البسيط
والمتوسط والتي يمكن التعامل معها من خلال
عيادات من خلالفه بان هذا بن الادمان مرض
مزمن وانه يمكن علاجه من خلال خدمات
التاهيليه او من خلال الخدمات المتخصصه
همم في حال كان همم هو بحاجه الى تدخلات
اضافيه كثير من الحالات تفقد يعني الامراض
الامراض الادمان المصاحبه تصلي نسبتها
بالنسبه للامراض النفسيه مصاحبه اصلا
نسبتها الى 40% وبالتالي 40% من الحالات
40% من الحالات النفسيه قد يوجد همم
الحالات الادمان 40% منهم لديهم همم امراض
نفسيه مصاحبه واحد اخطر عوامل همم الوقوع
في الادمان وجود امراض نفسيه مصاحبه قد
يكون بعض من ياتون لديهم همم
بفحصهم همم يمكن توجيههم للخدمات المت في
كان في حال كانوا بحاجه الى ذلك طيب دكتور
اليوم عندما تنتقل هذه العيادات لتصبح
المستشفيات العامه لتصبح اكثر من 50
مستشفى هل يعني ذلك انه لدينا حالات
متزايده في الادمان بالتاكيد كثير من
حالات تتجنب الذهاب المستشفيات المتخصصه
في مستشفيات الامل بسبب الوصمه وخلاف ذلك
فوجود مثل هذه الحالات يخف الوصمه يسهل
سهوله الوصول وهي تعتبر هذه المبادره هي
نواه همم لتفعيل دور همم النموذج الرعايه
الصحيه اللي يبدا من اسفل الهرم الى الى
الى اعلاء اشكرك جزيل الشكر على وجودك معي
في نشاره الرابعه الدكتور حسن خبراني الطب
النفسيه وقائد الطب الادمان بوزاره الصحه
شكرا دكتور شكرا
بهدف في تطوير القطاع السياحي في السعوديه
اعلنت وزاره السياحه اليوم عن اطلاق عشره
لوائح جديده بهدف حقيقي مستهدفات
استراتيجيه لتنميه السياحه الوطنيه
اللوائح الجديده شملت الانشطه السياحيه
وضبط الجوده ومراقبه الخدمات بالاضافه الى
تفعيل القطاع السياحي كما دعت وزاره
العاملين في القطاع الى تعديل اوضاعهم
والاستفاده من المهله والمحدده ب90 يوما
الى عمان حيث بدا اليوم اكثر من 70,000
داخل بالتصويت الاختياري ممثلهم في عضويه
المجالس البدل البلديه للفتره الثالثه عبر
تطبيق انتخب اتابع لوزاره الداخليه وتستمر
عمليه التصويت حتى السابع من مساء اليوم
لنحو 700 مترشح منهم 27 امراه
226 عضو في المجلس البلديه العمانيه
من مقر وزاره الداخليه العمانيه ينضم لنا
منفد العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي عبد
الرحمن مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض تبقى ساعه ونصف تقريبا
على نهايه الاقتراع انتخاب او التصويت
الالكتروني كيف تجد الامور كيف رصدتها
نعم نايف هناك تاكيدات حكوميه هنا في
سلطنه عمان على نجاح سير عمليه التصويت
حتى الان في محافظات السلطنه هناك اكيد
ايضا على نجاح خطه التصويت عبر تطبيق
انتخب هذه الطريقه التي لاول مره تطبق في
سلطنه عمان عبر الاجهزه الذكيه طبعا
نستطيع المتابعه الفرز وايضا التصويت عبر
تطبيق انتخاب هو تطبيق اخر مختلف عن تطبيق
انتخب الذي يتم من خلاله التصويت هذا
التطبيق همم يستطيع المتابع كما نشاهده
هنا ان يتاكد من عدد الناخبين همم الارقام
ايضا همم اعداد المحافظات وايضا مؤشرات
الانتخابات بشكل عام كما نشاهد حتى هذه
اللحظه نايف هناك تقريبا
140,000 من الذكور همم صوته وايضا اكثر من
7000 من
ايضا هناك جانب اخر في هذه الانتخابات وهو
حضور الاعلامي المميز حقيقه من جميع
الوسائل العالميه الحديث اكثر ينضم اليها
ساعده محمد البلوشي وكيل وزاره الاعلام
وهو ايضا عضو لجنه الرئيسيه الذي نحن
موجودين فيها الان في وزاره الداخليه
وايضا رئيس لجنه العلميه للانتخابات
المجالس البلديه سعد الوكيل نتحدث عن هذه
المره لا يوجد مراكز انتخابيه لا يوجد
مراكز اقتراع كلها الالكترونيه كيف
استطعتم تتعاملوا مع هذه الجزئيه في هذه
الانتخاب شكرا اخي عبد الرحمن شكرا على
هذه التقطيع من قناه العربيه حقيقه فيما
يتعلق بتغطيه الانتخابات سابقا كان يتم من
خلال المراكز الانتخابيه يتم توزيع
المذيعين والصحافيين على هذه المراكز بحيث
انه يتم تصويرها وتغطياتها على مدار اليوم
من الساعه 7:00 صباحا حتى الساعه السابعه
مساءا الان التحدي هو كيف ممكن تنقل هذه
الانتخابات عبر تطبيق انتخب هو تطبيق طبعا
بامكان ال- ال- المصوت ان يصوت في اي مكان
كان
وكان في البيت او في مكان في مقر عمله في
اي مكان فهذا هو التحدي حقيقه ان احنا من
خلال شاشات ربما
ما هو دور
شاشه 11 شاشه تبين كل شاشه تاخذ محافظه
بحيث انها تعرض بعض البيانات في هذه
المحافظه مثلا محافظه الوسطى تبين مثلا
يعني اعداد
المسجلين في السجل الانتخابي واعداد ايضا
المصوتين همم ايضا من ضمن المؤشرات
الموجوده في هذه الشاشات همم مؤشر الفئات
العمريه لكل ساعه ومؤشرات المصوتين همم
وتوزيع المصوتين حسب كل ولايه كيف رايته
بالتغطيه الاعلاميه حتى الان نسيمه من
وسائل الاعلام الاجنبيه والعربيه حقيقه
كانت ممتازه همم صباح اليوم تم زياره همم
مقر الانتخابات من قبل الصحفيين همم كذلك
تم اعطاهم شرح وافيه حول تطبيق انتخب
ومتابعه ايضا السياره العمليه الانتخابيه
من خلال متابعه همم تطبيق انتخاب الذي
يبين همم مؤشرات بشكل مباشر وكل ساعه يتم
تحديث هذه المؤشرات شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا
شكرا لقناه العربيه شكرا جزيلا كما شاهدنا
نايف يعني هناك جهود كبيره من قبل السلطات
العمانيه على انشاء هذه الانتخابات بعد
ساعه ونصف تبدا همم عمليه الفرز اولا باول
وتبدا ايضا نتائج تظهر اولا باول في ما
يتعلق بالفائزين في هذه الانتخابات
في العاصمه العمانيه مسقط
صناعه السفن التقليديه من ابرز ملامحي
ولايه صوره الساحليه بسلطنه عمان حيث تعمل
العديد من العائلات في هذه الصناعه
القديمه صالح جمعه حسون احدهم حيث ورث هذه
المهنه من اجداده الذين تخصصوا في هذه
الصناعه منذ القرن الثامن عشر الميلادي
عبد الرحمن العصيمي مع تفاصيل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
منذ عام
1730 وهذه العائله تعمل في صناعه السفن
التقليديه في ولايه الصور في سلطنه عمان
حيث تتوارث الاجيال هذه المهنه التي تشتهر
بها السلطنه لا سيما في المناطق الساحليه
[موسيقى]
المهنه هذه وورثناها احنا ابن عنجد
تقريبا احنا نكون اخر جيل ماسكين المهني
خلاص المصانع اول كانت اكثر من نصنع الحين
اخر مصنع في سلطنه عمان ويمكن في الخليج
اخر مصنع
صناعات خشبيه او يدويه
[موسيقى]
نحن هنا في اكبر هيكل لسفينه تقليديه في
سلطنه عمان هذه السفينه بدا العمل عليها
بدايات عام 2020 ومن المتوقع ان يتم
الانتهاء منها في اواخر العام المقبل
تكلفه هذه السفينه حوالي مليون دولار
امريكي
[موسيقى]
35 متر اللي هو يعادل تقريبا فوق 70 دراهم
فوق تقريبا من 50 الى 55 متر
نوعيه الاخشاب اللي موجوده فيهن السائق
اغلى انواع السائق او اغلى انواع
متوفره كانت من افريقيا
هذه المهنه تواجه الكثير من التحديات
ابرزها انتشار السفن المصنوعه من مواد
الحديثه مثل الفايبر جلاس بالاضافه الى
عزوف الشباب العماني عن هذه الصناعه
والله شيء يعور القلب يعني احنا الصناعات
التي ربينا عليه حرام
من الحكومه مين ينتظر مثل ما كانت مصانع
في صورها الحين
يضم هذا المصنع ورشه متخصصه بصناعه التحف
والمشغولات الخشبيه بالاضافه الى صاله
لعرض نماذج المصغره للسفن بكافه احجامها
وانواعها عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه
الصور العربيه
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
شتاء طنطوره ينطلق باحتفالات فنيه ويستمر
باستقبال زواره حتى الحادي والعشرين من
يناير
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد انطلق معرض العطور يوم
امس السبت
علامه تجاريه وخبراء العطور و رواد
الاعمال في المجال وسيستمر المعرض حتى
التاسع من يناير المقبل في واجهه الرياض
استقبال زواري الموسم خلال الفتره
المسائيه
من معرض العطور بواجهه الرياض ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد
المحسن مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض موسم جديد ومعرض همم
العطور مره اخرى يعود الى الرياض كيف هو
هذا العام انا اعتقد انك جئت الموسم
الماضي كمان عبد المحسن ولا
نعم صحيح نايف كنت موجود في معرض العطور
في الذي يقيم في فبراير في موسم رياض
الماضي وهذا هو النسخه الثانيه من هذا
المعرض الذي يضم ويعد اكبر تجمع
للعطور وشركاتها وروادها وايضا حتى همم
محبيها في هذا المعرض الذي يعيد تسويق
العطور وايضا يسهم في
نشرها وكذلك زياده همم الاستهلاك من قبل
الافراد وكذلك مساعده الشركات حتى الصغيره
لا يمكن هنالك مشاركات في العام الماضي او
في موسم الرياضي الماضي لشركات صغيره نمت
تطورت مشاركت بشكل اخر بفضل هذا المعرض
والمعرض الاخرى في همم السعوديه حيث تشكل
معارض العطور في السعوديه همم منصه كبيره
لبيع العطور في همم السعوديه وهي التي تعد
واحده من اهم الاسواق على مستوى
الوطن العربي وكذلك على مستوى الخليج تحدث
عن حجم مبيعات حائل
وايضا حجم نمو هائل الاستهلاك الفرد في
المملكه يبلغ لترين ونصف من العطر سنويا
مقابل 300 ملي يستهلكه الفرد في اوروبا
هنا مقارنه كما تشاهد في الصوره همم حيث
عدد من البراندات التي تشهد ازدحام كبير
وهذا هو منظر طبيعي في المعرض يعني همم
الازدحام الكبير والطوابير الطويله وهمم
الجميل في ذلك نايف ان هذه الطوابير
الطويله في معرض العطور هي ليست لبراندات
عالميه مشهوره همم اخذت حصتها من السوق
منذ 10 سنوات ولكن هذا هذا الطابور الكبير
هو لواحد من البرندات المحليه
والوطنيه التي بدات بالعمل واخذت حصتها من
هذا السوق وهو احد الاهداف الرئي طيب يا
عبد المحسن يعني يعني
مثل ما ذكرت هذه العلامات التجاريه هي
موجوده طبعا في الرياضه ويمكن عندها ايضا
كمان محلات موجوده في اكثر من موقع في
الرياضه وفي مناطق المملكه
ايش الجديد والمختلف اللي موجود في هذه
المحلات الموجوده لها داخل معرض العطور
اتحدث على خصومات ولا نتحدث على انواع
جديده موجوده في معرض العطور تكون حصريه
لهذا المعرض
نعم في الحقيقه ما يبحث عن المستهلكون هنا
في المعرض هو وجود هذا الكلمه الضخم من
البراندات على مستوى المعرض فبالتالي يوفر
لهم همم مساحه جيده يستطيعون من خلالها
اختيار العطر المناسب بالاضافه الى بعض
العروضات العروض والخصومات التي تقدمها
هذه الشركات سوف ان كان شركاته كبيره او
متوسطه او صغيره او حتى متناهيه الصغرى
شاهدت عدد من المشاركين همم الذين قدموا
عدد افرائهم عددهم ثلاثه اربعه فقط يقومون
بتركيب العطور ويبيعونه فبالتالي يشكل هذا
همم المعرض فرصه كبيره جدا همم لهم
بالمناسبه نايف كان هنالك عدد اتحدث عن
عدد الاستهلاك من ناحيه القيمه الماليه في
السعوديه 57 مليار دولار وهذا العدد من
الممكن والرقم ممكن ان يتطور خلال ربما
العام القادم بمعدل 7% فبالتالي هذا يعكس
حجم استهلاك الكبير وحجم السوق السعودي
همم بالعطور في السعوديه وفي المنطقه بشكل
عام انا اشكرك على حجم المعلومات الكبيره
اللي اعطيتني اياها اليوم المعرض العطور
بواجهه الرياض مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي شكرا لك
سجلت فعاليه واطلاق مربعانيه الشتاء
طنطوره في العلا حضورا كبيرا وذلك خلال
الايام الماضيه التي شهدتها لبلده القديمه
وذلك بعدد من الانشطه التي جسدها اكثر من
200 مشاركه من ابناء العلا والذي يعد
الاضخم منه
وشاهدت الفعاليات العديده من العروض
الثقافيه والانشطه التفاعليه التي تبرز
التاريخ العلا وعروض الضوء على جدران بلده
القديمه وقلعه البلده القديمه
[موسيقى]
اوي
في هذه الايام انقلبت الشمس في حركتها من
الجنوب الى الشمال وهكذا سنعيش اطول ساعات
الليل واقصر ساعات النهار التفاصيل في
تقويم عقد الزواج
[موسيقى]
في هذه الايام انقلبت شمس في حركتها من
الجنوب الى شمال وسنعيش خلال هذا الاسبوع
اطول ليالي
واقصر نهر في السنه على الاطلاق وفي نقطه
الانقلاب ينفتح علينا من الشتاء باب
ويتزامل ذلك مع النجم الثالث من نجوم
المربعانيه المسمى بشوله والعامه يقولون
اذا طلعت شوله طال الليل طوله واعجله
الشيخ البول واشتدت على العاقل
العوله
في نهايه هذا الاسبوع يبدا النهار ياخذ
حصته من الليل ويستمر في الاخذ لمده ثلاثه
شهور تقريبا وحين ذاك يتساوى في طول الليل
مع النهار في شهر مارس المسمى باذار اذا
طلع ابا ذر تساوي الليل مع النهار وطول
ساعات الليل على بلدان الخليج خلال هذه
الايام تتجاوز 13 ساعه تقريبا والشمس
غايبه على القطب الشمالي له ثلاثه شهور
ولن تشرق الا بعد ثلاثه شهور في الليل سته
شهور والنهار سته شهور والشمس الان في
ضيافه القطب الجنوب لن يرحل الحزن منك ما
دمت
تحسم ضيافته
[موسيقى]
نختم الرابعه
توقف عملياتها في افغانستان
انيابه العمل السعوديه تطير دليلا
لاجراءات البحث والتحري والضبطي في جرائم
التستر
مصادر العربيه تكشف عن بدء صحه السعوديه
تفعيل المستشفيات العامه لعيادات الادمان
اكثر من 700000 ابن عمانيه يبداون التصويت
الكترونيا لاختيار اعضاء المجلس البلديه
السياحه السعوديه تعلن عن 10 لوائح جديده
لتحقيق مصادفه استراتيجيه السياحه الوطنيه
[موسيقى]